He says,
have you read much Thomas Soul?
In many ways,
he filled your societal role for the
last generation from a different academic
perspective.
I'm just reading his book right now.
It's,
what is it,
white,
black,
red Nixon,
white liberals?
Is that right?
Black rednecks and white liberals.
Yeah.
I,
I'm,
I'm still making my mind up about it.
It's quite a radical idea.
I mean,
in that book,
so claims that black urban culture is
actually a derivative of southern cracker
culture,
and that that in turn is a derivative
of a rather dysfunctional Highland
dysfunctional British culture.
What would you call rural called British
rural culture from a couple of hundred
years ago?
Um,
I'm still thinking it through.
I find the book really interesting and it,
it wouldn't surprise me if it was true,
but it's quite original.
The thesis is quite original.
So I'm,
I'm working my way through that right
now and I don't have anything much more
intelligent to say than that.